last week the government watchdog
criticized hs2 saying that no one
foresaw the scale and risk of the
project but former senior executives
have told Sky News that when it came to
the costs of purchasing land for the
project they had tried to warn HS - back
in 2015 and what I listed was there are
11,000 420 properties we need to buy I
showed them the of that almost 50
percent in 48 percent hit zero value
against them that was a shock to them I
do not think that they realized that
only half the properties we needed to
buy had been costed the former head of
planning and performance at HS - Andrew
Bruce had 30 years experience on
engineering projects in the military and
private sector he says he was sacked on
the day he was due to present his
findings to the board and that HS - did
that because they didn't want Parliament
to know that costs would go up
absolutely apartment has been mislaid I
think HS - I have no doubt whatsoever
knew the true value of the land and they
concealed that they did not and present
that to Parliament they gave a 2013
figure from CBRE based less than 2.8
billion which was the estimated sum a
report by the National Audit Office in
2018 found that Parliament didn't
require HST to update its estimate and
it absolved the company of allegations
made by mr. Bruce but mr. Bruce feels
vindicated by the latest watchdog report
they show that wild parliament approved
a land cost figure of 2.8 billion for
phase one after purchasing 66% of the
land HS - has already spent 3.3 billion
on land and that would suggest that mr.
Bruce's estimate of a total cost of 4.8
billion could be very accurate
mr. Bruce's boss when he arrived at HS -
was Doug Thornton
he was also sacked he says because he
refused to present inaccurate figures
for land costs - the non-executive board
I was asked to provide information to HS
to his non-executive board that I
believe was severely misleading based on
the data that was in front of me
as land and property director I believe
if I had advanced that information to HS
to is non-executive board as I was being
asked to then I would have been in
breach of my obligations as a as a
director of the organisation Sky News
has seen affidavits from three former
executives criticizing hs2 for failing
to properly estimate its costs hs2 said
these allegations are simply not true
and predate the current leadership of HS
two limited furthermore the claims made
by mr. Bruce were put under intense
scrutiny in 2018 by the National Audit
Office as part of an investigation into
the HS 2 projects property cost
estimates the NAO report published in
September 2018 found nothing untoward
and concluded that the revised 2016 cost
estimate was reasonable but a third
former executive has now emerged as a
critic HS 2's former program delivery
strategy director says the latest
watchdog report is damning what you
shouldn't be doing is going ahead with
construction until you've got a viable
firm business case obviously a no report
and the current leaked figures on
6,000,000,000 says they got it wrong
well as the yeah it needs need to be
read and fully reproved at the stage
when you say reprove do you think it
should go back to Parliament again
that's not for me to say but you know
they approved in the first place so
therefore it really should go back to
Parliament because the situation has
changed
for now it's up to the Prime Minister to
assess all of this he's expected to make
a decision on HS too early next month
Jason Farrell Sky News